Newark itch was held to a would have 11
rebounds the other night holiday drives
inside for to pitch and they've done a
nice job since the timeout
they lost Holliday who rocks the rim for
New Orleans raccattack Jew holiday we
should get a third and fourth but watch
him come in with the left hand and just
fly over the top of Newark it's such a
smooth score 21 points four points per
game the drive and finish holiday and
the fans now poorest with the defense
chants coming down and the Blazers have
their first lien holiday the dribble
penetration so tough going to the goal
only to throw attempts in this opening
quarter Chuck walk is down to four
holiday again true holiday is locked and
loaded
[Applause]
Lazer's back in front
holiday they can't stop them they shot
it at 46% in that first half and the
Blazers bench playing a key role but
holiday pick it up where he left off a
way you could even get to it this game
at the time any of these possessions 56
field goal attempts for Portland in the
first and holiday back to rim action
maybe that's something we can examine as
we go on
gasps playing this fat oh holiday nails
it from jigs able to slip it to holiday
on this cut amazing on the inside and
drew with a beautiful move score for
holiday holiday alone to the corner
beach rings it you can hold off this
late run by before we get way out of the
timeout crashes over holiday works
inside for two holiday mismatched
holiday pulls up he's on there shame Oh
three balls for true holiday to the last
holiday played they cleared out the
entire side forum and a rhythm dribble
just stepped into it you see his